بدون شك يعني قراءتك لهذه الظواهر انت
عالجت في اكثر من بحث يعني على مدار سنوات
طبعا الغرب مر في هذه المرحله من انماط
الاستبداد الاصلي نحن كانه الاستبداد
المستبدون عنا هني نسخ شبه مشوهه عن عن
مصغره عن
والغرب تقريبا انتهى من هذه المراحل مع
الحرب العالميه الثانيه والان العالم
العربي منذ 12 عام تقريبا يعني في مخاض
مخاض للتخلص من من هذه الصيغ من الانظمه
المستبده اذا صح قول يعني ولكن على ما
يبدو لا افق لانه ايضا برز على الساحه نوع
اخر من من الاستبداد هو الاستبداد المعتمد
على على
تاويل الديني اذا صح القول ايضا هذا شو
السبب اللي خلاه يبرز بها الخوه مع مع ما
سمي الربيع العربي يعني ويخطف هذه الامال
شوف في سببين السبب الاساسي انه جماهيرنا
عند هذه القابليه لانه لم تبنى اوطان
كيانات وطنيه لم تبنى دول وطن بعد بالمعنى
الماء بالمعنى المتعارف عليه غربيا ويلي
توصف الناس تنصف المواطن وتحمي تعطي حقوقه
وتحميه وتطلب منه واجباته فالناس تلجا الى
الغيبيات
وبالتالي كانت الجماهير
المقهوره والمهدوره
مهيئه لانه تتبع رجال الدين باعتبار انه
الدين هو الخلاص الوحيد او الملاذ الوحيد
المتبقي الهم هذا واحد
اثنين فشل
المشاريع القوميه كانت مشاريع فوقيه مش
كثير اشتغلت على
البنى القاعديه مثل ما عملت اوروبا اوروبا
ما عملوا ثوره فوقي الثوره الفوقيه
الاوروبيه مثل الحداثه والمواطنه والحريه
والديمقراطيه هيدي اتت لخدمه ثوره صناعيه
اساسيه قامت يعني ونحن مثقفين
بيعدوا بيشتغلوا بالثقافه وبالحداثه
وبالفكره وبالديمقراطيه بشكل فوقي معزول
عن واقع بقى له اكثر من 900 سنه منذ
الهجمه المغوليه علينا ودمار حضارتنا
ولم تقم
عندنا ثورات صناعيه حقيقي